man muss dazu sagen die impfbereitschaft
in deutschland steigt stetig doch ein
teil der bevölkerung wurde bislang
leider doch nicht beachtet dass sie die
kinder unter 16 jahren für die gibt es
noch keinen impfstoff warum nicht das
möchte ich jetzt mit dem kinderarzt
carsten marten sprechen
guten tag
woran liegt das denn das ist noch kein
impfstoff für die unter 16-jährigen gibt
ich meine das macht 20 prozent unserer
bevölkerung aus das macht immerhin 13,5
millionen menschen aus das ist klar aber
man muss einfach auch verstehen konnte
bis eine studie gemacht mit kindern
eltern müssen wegen und da kommt die
ethik kommission dazu
es ist viel viel schwieriger sozusagen
probanden zu kriegen die einem studien
mitmachen aber freundlicherweise laufen
jetzt ja solche studien also gerade von
den drei großen firmen die zulassung für
europa haben laut studien und da muss
man die ergebnisse abwarten
man muss natürlich darf gucken wie es
die dosis für kinder kinder haben ja ein
anderes immunsystem also die
jugendlichen dies in erster linie die
auch interessant sind natürlich die
meinen zehn- bis 16-jährigen da ist es
sicher nicht so ein problem aber je
jünger die kinder sind desto anders kann
auch das immunsystem reagierenden es
geht ja in erster linie auch darum ist
die impfung wirksam
also ich glaube nicht dass kinder mehr
nebenwirkungen haben werden als
erwachsene
bei diesem sehr gut vertragen im sturm
aber es gibt vor allem um die
wirksamkeit und die frage zu sein ist
die dosis die gleiche wie bei
erwachsenen im kart schon die studien
angesprochen die da gerade laufen also
die versuche dann auch ein kinder
impfstoff rauszubringen sie mit ihrer
erfahrung als verkaufen womit rechnen
sie denn wann das soweit ist mit einem
kinder impfstoff ich denke das wird so
im spiel zu mein herz sein so langsam ja
noch diese studien laufen und man muss
dann einfach auch mal gucken gut wenn
sich herausstellen sollte dass das ein
sozusagen der impfstoff eine stabile
immunität lacht also dass auch keine wir
in der nase zumindest an schrecken
das muss man erst mal raus bin es ist ja
zweierlei wenn man auch gewisse die
anmeldung der nase hat das wird sicher
sein
aber wenn das virus renten geben von
antikörpern ist und der das kind oder
der erwachsenen nicht mehr anstecken
kann dann wird man natürlich auch kinder
helfen
und man muss ja einfach sehen es besteht
natürlich die gefahr wenn eben im sommer
war sie eine realität bei den
erwachsenen haben was kann dann das
virus machen es wird dann auf die kinder
übergeben
das haben wir ja zum beispiel in den
letzten 20 jahren bei kingston gesehen
wie kinderärzte sind brave ärzte wir wo
die ganzen kinder leben und auf einmal
wurde die kinderkrankheit feuchtesten
eine kranke die erwachsenen aber das
wollen wir natürlich nicht bei corona
wenn es denn 17 millionen kinder eben
theoretisch gefährdet sind und auch wenn
dann nur ein promille schwer krank das
sind dann auch zu viele also ich glaube
wenn ein impfstoff da ist sollte er auch
dann im herbst für kinder zugänglich
sein und ich glaube auch da das ist hier
schon meiner fragen der praxis werden
die eltern bereit sein dazu gerade die
eltern natürlich wo die kinder
grundkrankheiten haben schwere
lungenkrankheiten
die fahren ja heute schon nach beckers
und wie kann ich es erreichen dass mein
kind eine impfung bekommen und eine
einzelfallentscheidung kann es immer
geben auch wenn der impfstoff noch nicht
zugelassen wird kann ich mir vorstellen
dass schon im sommer es kommt wenn eben
kinder schwere lungenerkrankung haben
kinder beatmet werden wo eben eine kurve
in eine infektion über lebensgefährlich
werden dann kann ich mir vorstellen dass
im einzelfall denn auch mein kind
geimpft werden wird herr dr carsten was
bedeutet dass ein blick auf die schul
und kind eröffnungen jetzt gehe ich ist
es erst mal wichtig da natürlich dass
die lehrer beziehungsweise die jetzt ihr
wm pferd das wo natürlich schon lange
dass die mich jetzt in erster reisen
denn wenn man sich genau an co wenn
kinder kannten gerade bei den kleineren
war es ja selten dass das kind zu kind
sich angesteckt hat sondern es waren oft
das sozusagen die gefährte waren die
lehrer bzw waren die erzieher und ich
denke wenn die geimpft sind
gerade bei den kleinen klassen dann kann
man eigentlich doch wieder mit einem
besseren gefühl
die schulen öffnen also das ist glaube
ich ganz ganz wichtig dass man sagt dass
zumindestens die lehrer und die erzieher
sozusagen das beagle sozusagen jetzt in
erster linie geimpft werden